deranged Jack Smith and I watched them
yesterday go up and talk he talked for
about two and a half minutes he was
shaking he was so scared
he didn't want to be there
because ultimately these are cowards
they're cowards
and he's a big Trump hater openly he's a
trump hater and his wife is even more of
a Trumpeter
[Music]
the ridiculous and baseless indictment
of Me by the Biden administration's
weaponized Department of Injustice
we'll go down is among the most horrific
abuses of power in the history of our
country many people have said that
Democrats have even said it this vicious
persecution is a travesty of Justice
you're watching Joe Briden job I think
of it Biden is trying to jail his
leading political opponent an opponent
that's beating him by a lot in the polls
just like they do in stalinist Russia or
communist China
they took one charge and they made it 36
different times
and we have a thug who's in charge this
is
a political hit job Republicans are
treated far differently at the justice
department than Democrats